[Musique]
belga le danton et 7 à vancouver
quartiers touchés de plein fouet par la
crise des surdoses beaucoup qui réclame
la décriminalisation de la possession
simple de drogue
c'est l'un des combats de guy felice la
ex consommateurs de drogue qui a vécu 20
ans dans ce quartier difficile et il est
sobre depuis sept ans et habite
maintenant une maison en banlieue de
vancouver avec sa femme et ses trois
enfants dans son ancienne vie il a
survécu à ces surdoses en moins d'un an
tout le monde n'a pas sa chance jusqu'à
présent en 2020 près de 1400 personnes
sont mortes d'une surdose de drogue en
colombie britannique
c'est près de cinq par jour le fentanyl
un des pionniers de 40 fois plus
puissant que l'héroïne a été détecté
dans environ 90 % des cas
le conseil municipal de vancouver a
formellement demandé au gouvernement
fédéral de décriminaliser la possession
simple de drogue à vancouver en
soustrayant la ville de la loi qui
réglemente les drogues
le message sera-t-il entendu par ottawa
de plus en plus de voix appellent en
tout cas le gouvernement à agir
le premier ministre de la
colombie-britannique la médecin en chef
de la province boni et nuit et même
l'association canadienne des chefs de
police soutiennent la décriminalisation
des drogues
tous soulignent qu'il faut voir la
dépendance non pas comme un problème
criminels mais comme un problème de
santé
soit sur un loupé les baigneurs dans les
rues du downtown eastside usage de
substances se fait souvent qu'ils ont vu
et au su de tous incluant les policiers
une directive du service de police de
vancouver leur interdit d'arrêter
quelqu'un juste parce qu'il possède une
petite quantité de drogue pour son usage
personnel
une politique qui encourage les
policiers à utiliser leur pouvoir
discrétionnaire pour ne pas intervenir
dans des cas où il n'ya pas preuve de
danger public
mais cette discrétion laisser aux
policiers peut poser problème affirme le
professeur les utilisateurs de drogues
mais savent pas toujours à quoi s'en
tenir
le pendant du policier que rencontre la
réaction peu différent selon lui une
politique nationale s'impose pour
garantir une certaine uniformité entre
les différentes juridictions et éviter
la répression
par exemple le simple fait de confisquer
des drogues à une personne dépendante
souligne ce médecin s'avère
contre-productif c'est médical que moi
je me semble par exemple si tu passeras
je vais commencer à voir le sevrage
comme vraiment j'ai l'impression de
mourir puis qu'est-ce que refaire pas il
faut chercher ma prochaine drogue ce qui
peut mener la personne à commettre des
crimes mineurs comme le vol est
entraînée cette fois une arrestation qui
pousse aussi le consommateur stigmatisé
à se cacher si les promoteurs de la
décriminalisation de s'entendent pas
nécessairement sur la marche à suivre
une fois ce premier pas franchi
ils font le même constat le statu quo
n'est plus tenable
timothy mc bergeron radio canada
vancouver